hey you guys welcome back once again to
flickers of fear my movie review series
so probably like a lot of the movies
that i end up watching and covering on
this little series here
i can't remember
exactly how i first heard about today's
movie which is called super dark times
and it came out in 2017.
now this was an independent film
and it was actually the directorial
debut of a cinema who uh cinematographer
named kevin phillips he had previously
been a cinematographer this is his first
uh directive director's job i think he's
done a couple more since then but i
haven't seen either one of them
and this movie also when it came out in
2017 it actually managed to get the hr
giger award for best feature film at the
uh neu chatel i'm hoping i'm pronouncing
that right uh international fantastic
film festival in switzerland back in
2017 or 2018 i believe it was so it got
like the uh the best feature that year
now i think i heard about it probably
how i hear about a lot of the newer
movies that i uh watch for the show i
probably saw it pop up on a couple of
those you know best horror films on film
streaming service here lists and thought
it sounded like pretty cool and right up
my alley so i finally got around to
watching it incidentally the screenplay
for this was written by
ben collins and uh luke pietrowski and
they also wrote another movie that i
covered on here not too long ago which
was the nighthouse with rebecca hall
so this movie
it's less a straightforward horror film
i feel like and it's more kind of like a
grim sort of like coming of age
psychological thriller but that said
this movie is actually a very very
assured
first feature um it's very very tension
filled it's just very bleak it's very
unsettling and it's just kind of like
looking into i guess like teenagers and
like the aftermath of a tragedy so i've
seen it compared to movies like mean
creek uh with which i think had rory
culkin in it uh rivers edge donnie darko
stand by me so like those kind of movies
those are actually really good
comparisons to this because this is a
very similar kind of you know ballpark
as those um i mean it has this kind of
like
i don't know i guess i would call it
like maybe like a poisonous nostalgia
type of
thing about sort of the dark side of
teenage lives and relationships and
stuff like that like prior to the
internet era
so the movie actually opens up on a
really brilliant and really chilling
scene which actually doesn't have
anything specifically to do with the
events in the movie that follow but it
actually kind of foreshadows and it sets
up this really uneasy mood so i really
liked it
so at the beginning of the movie we
close in on this like almost like sort
of deserted looking school building and
it has like one broken window and then
you go inside and like all the papers
are kind of blowing around there's
nobody in the classroom at first and but
the classroom's all disordered and like
the desks are all askew and then you see
that there's like blood all over the
floor
now it turns out like as this scene goes
on that what has happened is that a deer
has crashed through the window and is
laying on the floor like in the process
of dying and at that point like the cops
come in and they don't seem to be like
entirely sure like what to do about it
and then one of the cops comes in and
just kind of almost like angrily like
stomps the deer to death like to put it
out of its misery like while one of the
students like out in the hall like looks
on with horror so like i said this
doesn't have anything directly to do but
it's just kind of like a foreshadowing
moment and i thought it was like really
well done so from there we kind of move
into the story proper now this is set in
the early to mid 1990s i'm so like uh
bill clinton was on the tv and was
president at some point so i guess it
had to be like post 1992 and it appears
to be i believe it was shot in the
hudson valley in uh upstate new york
so super dark times we're following two
best friends
one of them is named zack he's kind of
like the main character and he's
actually played by owen campbell who i
recently saw in another couple of movies
that i
covered he was in uh my heart can't beat
unless you tell it to from 2020 and also
uh in x the thai west movie from 2021 i
think he had a small part in that as
well um so he plays zack and then the
other kid is named josh and he's
actually played by uh charlie tahan i
think is how you pronounce his last name
if i if that's not right i apologize uh
he actually started out as a kid actor i
think he was an i am legend like the
2007 one and he's also on the tv series
ozark he's on like a bunch of like
different tv series and movies and stuff
like that
so for the first bit of the movie i
don't even remember how long it was like
maybe the first 15 20 minutes maybe not
that long i can't really uh i don't
really remember but for the first part
of the movie we're just kind of like
hanging out
with these two teenage boys like
establishing their characters
establishing their relationship like
their world or whatever and we're
hanging out with them and they're doing
like what teenage boys did in the 1990s
like i said before there was uh internet
you know they're trying to look at
scrambled porn on the tv they're uh
playing minesweeper like on the old like
compact computers or whatever it was
like oh man i remember that kind of like
going through their yearbooks and like
lusting over pictures of their female
classmates and like talking about
talking [ __ ] about like all the stuff
that they would do to each one of them
and all this other kind of stuff riding
bikes around the neighborhood a la
stranger things and things like that so
all that just talking [ __ ] to one
another like teenage boys do uh i will
say too that the acting in this is
superb uh having been a high school
student myself in the late 1980s so i
would have been like a couple years
older than you know the kids in this
movie would have been in the context of
this movie and i can tell you that this
is like pretty much absolutely uh what
teenage boys did like their activities
like before there was an internet and
the way that they talked to one another
um it was just eerily spot-on
plus i have like two younger brothers as
well uh and so the acting of this is
just so naturalistic
that i found it really difficult to
believe that these actors i checked
weren't even born when this movie was
supposed to be set which really blows my
mind i mean they did they did a great
great job
so this being like i said the early to
mid 90s so this is way before cell
phones kind of before real structured
like after school activities before like
helicopter parenting really became a
thing so at this stage much like in the
80s uh you know these boys and their
classmates are kind of like left to
their own devices like their parents a
lot of them you know most of them are
latch key kids their parents work uh so
their parents don't usually get home
until after dark so they get home from
school and then they're just kind of
like farting around they can pretty much
do whatever they want for several hours
um and when the parents are there
they're not neglectful like no none of
the parents in this seem like neglectful
or you know terrible parents or anything
really other than like a couple hints
like for some side characters but they
just kind of like uh you know they're
not just hovering over the kids all the
time they're just kind of like you know
at one point like zack's mom
she appears to be a single mother and
zack's mom just kind of like lets this
girl that he likes come over and they
just go back like down in his room and
stuff like that and she's just like hey
she's kind of cute you know what i mean
she's not like hovering like seeing what
they're doing so it's all that kind of
thing now the thing about this though is
that
that could end up being a good thing or
a bad thing like depending on your
perspective i mean obviously the
teenagers are into it because they like
you know they have a lot of unstructured
time where they can just do whatever
they want but you know on the flip side
of that there's also a lot of room where
they're not supervised and they can get
into a lot of trouble which is what
happens in this movie
so i will say too that it seems very
relevant and i think
if i'm not because i did read some other
kind of like interviews and some other
uh reviews of this and i think that
it was brought up either maybe by the
the filmmakers or whatever but they
didn't
set this in the early 90s just to be
like just to write on the nostalgia
train they're like we wanted to kind of
convey this story in the time before
particularly the columbine massacre like
which i kind of feel like changed the
way that certain types of teenage
behaviors were seen not only by the
authority figures in their lives but
also like by society as a whole so i
kind of feel like that's probably
relevant that it was set before that and
interestingly too i think one of the
things that really contributes to the
sort of mood of this movie which i
really got into was that the town itself
where these boys live
it appears like kind of a small town and
kind of economically depressed like it
seems like a lot of the buildings are
maybe like abandoned or there's like you
know high crime or something like that
like there's a lot of graffiti and uh
things of that nature and also when
they're going around doing things the
town looks empty like most of the time
like you don't really see like other
people really like walking around or
driving around or anything like that so
it gives the movie this real kind of
like desolate like almost a
post-apocalyptic kind of feel like
almost it doesn't go that it's not you
know that much of out there but just the
fact that they walk around these like
empty streets and stuff and i think it
really gives a good um it really conveys
the sense that these kids are like
completely alone and cut off not only
from like their parents and their
teachers and things like that but also
from maybe like the wider world at large
so while zach and josh are frittering
away an afternoon uh one day by riding
bikes and you know going to the
convenience store and buying snacks and
you know just shooting the [ __ ] like
like teenage boys do
they happen to meet up with this kid
they seem to like sort of know him his
name is daryl and i guess he's sort of
like an unpopular kid at school like
everybody just thinks he's kind of like
a dork or a loser or whatever and uh but
daryl is hanging out there with his
friend charlie who is younger he's like
in middle school i think he's like an
8th grader or something like that so i i
guess that kind of like cements like
daryl's like loser status because he's
hanging out with like younger kids
now while they're all hanging out josh
who i guess he kind of wants to like
show off a bit so he takes the kids like
back to his house and lets them into his
older brother's room now his older
brother is like away in the marines and
has been away for like a year or
something like that
now the room is like a teenage boy's
fantasy you know what i mean there's
like pinups and like porn like stuck all
over the walls and the ceiling and stuff
like that there's a bunch of weed the
guy left behind like a pretty
significant amount of weed i was like
holy crap why would he leave that behind
but yeah so we left that behind and uh
most significantly there's a nice sharp
katana which belongs to the brother
now daryl wants to smoke the weed but
josh gets really mad and he's like hey
that belongs to my brother like you
don't have any right to take it and he's
just like yeah he won't be coming back
for like he's been gone a long time but
they have a kind of argument but then
daryl's just kind of like okay fine
whatever man it's your weed it's your
brother so what they decide to do though
is they decide to take the katana um and
decide that they're gonna go [ __ ] around
with it so they go kind of out to this
uh empty field and they're gonna slice
milk cartons open and you know they're
just kind of like quarreling about
stupid teenage boy [ __ ] like about girls
and about superheroes and all that kind
of stuff however a problem soon arises
uh when they discover that daryl
absolutely stole all the weed from
josh's brother's bedroom and it's like
sitting there smoking it like a dumbass
i think that kind of
i think we're meant to assume like he
doesn't seem like he's uh i don't know
like daryl seems like maybe he's not
slow necessarily but maybe not the
sharpest tool in the shed you know what
i mean i don't want to like overstate
that but because he obviously stole all
this weed and then he just sits there
and feels full view of everybody like
smoking it and just no no it's just a
regular cigarette and i'm just like yeah
that's not gonna fly but anyway so uh so
he starts smoking it and obviously like
josh gets really mad um because he's
like hey i told you not to take that so
they get into this really big heated
argument which ends with josh kind of
accidentally uh stabbing daryl in the
throat with the katana
now the boys all understandably freak
out uh and try to kind of stem the tide
of blood that's coming out of this kid's
neck and they wig out even more as you
would when daryl who seems to be running
like purely on adrenal at this point
like actually gets up like gets onto his
feet and like runs off into the woods so
they chase him obviously but by the time
they catch up to him uh daryl has bled
out and is just laying there dead on the
forest floor
so
the three other boys are like what the
[ __ ] do we do now they're completely
panicked so they're like well you know
no one's gonna believe this is an
accident what's you know what are we
gonna do so they decide well we're gonna
hide the body and the sword and now
we're gonna like pretend that we have no
idea what happened and no idea where
this kid went to because like i said
they weren't
they sort of knew each other like that
they went to the same school but they
didn't like hang out together so it
wouldn't like be really obvious that you
know they didn't usually hang out with
that kid so it wouldn't be really
obvious that like people were like hey
where'd that kid go so from that point
in the movie onward uh sort of like the
friendship between josh and zach
starts crumbling i guess as each of them
is just trying to deal with this secret
in their own way and like i said the
other kid charlie neither of them really
knew him either and he's like younger so
he doesn't go to the same school as them
so he's just kind of like whatever like
we're not friends and like stop talking
to me so he just kind of like goes and
does his own thing
now zach who seems to be like more of an
empathetic person he's actually like
consumed by guilt he's thinking about oh
my god like daryl's mother must be
worried sick about him and it's like you
know everybody thinks the kid is just
missing because obviously they haven't
found the body and he's like but i know
where he is and i know what happened to
him and it's like eating him up inside
that he can't tell anybody about it and
so he's almost kind of like tempted i
don't think that he necessarily wants to
report it he never says that but he does
say a couple of times that that they
should go back
to
um to the spot where they left the body
and like check on it or you know or do
something you know he he's he seems like
he wants to do something about it which
i think maybe is like a low-key way that
maybe he wants to get caught so he
doesn't have to worry about it anymore
he's also really conflicted by the fact
because this is another little side plot
that this girl that he's like totally in
love with his name is allison has kind
of like started flirting back and like
returning his feelings hey i really like
you and stuff like that too and he's
still a teenage boy so he really really
wants to pursue this but obviously he
has this horrible horrific secret that's
just like eating him up and killing him
inside and he's just too emotionally
distraught to
return the feelings as much as he wants
to and you know he really wants to tell
her like why he's being that way but he
can't because he'll get in trouble now
josh on the other hand who was more
directly responsible for the kid dying
uh actually locks himself away in his
room for several days like telling his
mom that he's really sick and but then
when he comes back out of his room like
when he emerges and goes back to school
he sort of acts like nothing happened
like that's kind of how he's dealing
with it he's just like yeah whatever and
he's just like acting all cool and
everything um but he does seem to be
like lashing out or like acting out in
ways that he didn't really before like
he's getting in trouble at school like
he calls his teacher like a [ __ ] and
stuff like that which he wouldn't have
done before because he was more of a
quiet kid so
that's kind of how his stress is coming
out in that way um and he's just
generally acting sort of off so
obviously like him like zach and uh josh
aren't really talking that much anymore
because they're dealing with this
with what happened in like such a
different way and they can't really
communicate and so but zack starts to
get really worried when another
classmate of theirs uh who josh
absolutely despised
turns up dead also like in an apparent
accident or suicide and zack starts to
suspect that maybe josh had something to
do with it
so as i mentioned uh this is actually
way more like a dark thriller about
teenage relationships and murder than a
traditional horror film but i actually
think that certain types of horror fans
will probably really dig it like i said
especially if you like stuff like donnie
darko or stand by me or river's edge or
something like that which like i said
are not necessarily horror films but
they have like real dark themes to them
so i think if you liked those you would
probably like this as well like i said
it has that kind of like dark nostalgia
kind of uh deal to it as well and it has
like this real ominous vibe
to it that makes you like the whole time
you're watching it you just feel like
things could spiral out of control like
at any minute because you're not really
sure
what exactly is going to happen like how
this is all going to play out
so i mean the acting is impeccable i
guess it's very very naturalistic and it
really kind of uh evoked that era for me
because i was like yeah i remember like
teenage boys acting like that and
talking like that uh the cinematography
is beautiful um even though it's very
very forbidding like i said it's almost
kind of like almost post-apocalyptic
like the way that it's shot and i will
give a special shout out here too to the
score and also like the musical choices
like the songs they used their songs by
uh black flag bad religion wire the
comsat angels i think pm dawn was in
there stuff like that and it really set
this kind of like somber but also kind
of like real anxiety inducing like mood
and it really really took me back to
that time because like i said 90s 92
something like that i was just out of
high school like i was in college at
that time so this this arrow is like
really a hype in my mind so i was kind
of like just a little bit older than
these kids would have been so there was
like a lot that i could relate to from
this uh but yeah this is a really really
good one if you really really like kind
of like dark dramas especially about you
know [ __ ] up stuff happening to like
teenagers uh then i would definitely
recommend it to anybody that was into
that kind of stuff uh i really really
enjoyed it so if you've seen it like let
me know what you thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you again on
the next one bye